you got
[Music]
happy Friday y'all welcome to certified
country we will get to more with Kenny
Rogers in just a minute but first I've
got some good news and I've got some bad
news just like a band-aid here's the bad
we're gonna rip it off this is our final
episode of certified country for now
because and here's the good news
I'm having a baby if you've been paying
attention to the show at all you've
probably noticed that by now but I'm
officially over 30 weeks pregnant I am
tired
I'm overheated I'm swollen and I'm very
very happy but it's time for a break so
I'm leaving you today with a very
special flashback episode with a legend
here's Kenny Rogers as he announced his
retirement last fall
[Music]
the table
[Music]
I want to play a little game of
over-under and I assume you know how
over/under work we'll try it okay I'm
gonna see if you know some of these
stats about your very impressive career
hit singles two have charted I'm gonna
give you the number 110 I'm gonna say no
cheating under over 120 over 120 Wow
it's amazing isn't it
I am DB acting credits I'll give you 30
uh hi I'm no actor and I've got 11
movies to prove it together two ex-cons
must stop the biggest casino heist ever
no way to treat a pain guess I'll say
under under is right you've got 23 Wow
I'm busy
soundtrack credits so how many pieces of
work do you think your songs have been
featured in I'll give you 100 over right
[Music]
peak number of Kenny Rogers Roasters
I'll give you 400 how bad in this
country it's still alone oh that's under
under but not by much 350 according to
Wikipedia is Wikipedia wrong last one
number of Grammy nominations you have
received I'll give you 10 over 15 oh did
you know it was 15 no I had no clue I
remember standing there with Dottie West
backstage and we were up for a Grammy on
something but I mean she was crying she
was so excited she was a very special
girl
what made you the most excited in your
crew I think working with dollies
[Music]
I don't know how you can do that not
that that'd be the most exciting thing
that ever happens to you she's
incredible
she is that as are you what is your
favorite thing about massage her smile
and the fact that the interesting thing
is Ali likes you then no matter what she
says because she doesn't think about
what she's saying a lot
you know what no matter what she says it
comes from love and if you take it that
way you can't be offended by it but
she's a very special girl what is the
most like Dolly thing that dolly has
said to you well not long ago we were
recording you can't make old friends
uh-huh and I look over and and I was
kind of it was our story and I was very
touchy and I looked over and she was
gone I started looking for her she came
around the corner did she put her arms
around my neck she said Kenny want you
to know something I could never sing at
your funeral so we're assuming I'm going
first is that what you're but that's so
typical I mean it was a wonderful
statement about how she felt
[Music]
now you have a big birthday coming up oh
man 80 that's impressive
that's amazing that's impressive you
should be pressing to me no stop it's
one of those things that you always say
when you're young I hope I can live to
be 80 when you get up here and your
mobility such they can't do anything so
why are you what be excited about I mean
you have achieved so much though in your
years you must have so many incredible
memories I look back on so what would
you say is your greatest accomplishment
I think possibly and maybe I'm taking
credit for something I'm sure but I
think the fact that I think I introduced
country music to a lot of people that
prior to that had not bought it in like
in New York and New Jersey and I think
that was a great accomplishment to kind
of open those doors is that what you
hope to be remembered for yeah oh that's
that's all I I don't need much thank you
Tony well that's that's a big one
Kenny's 80th birthday will be on August
21st coincidentally that's just two days
after my due date with baby girl so who
knows we might have some birthday
buddies on our hands here I don't want
to say goodbye so I won't I will say see
you later certified country fan you can
continue following my journey on social
media at Sophie Chalet see for updates
on all my latest interviews and
eventually yes baby pictures I'm sorry
in advance I will try not to spam you
but please don't hold me to that thank
you so much for joining me on this
journey more than four and a half
million of you have tuned in over the
last year and I'm so so grateful for
each and every one of you I just I I
don't have the words for it so I will
just say thank you for watching and bye
for now
okay we good I have to pee
[Music]
you